ah si on m'avait dit qu'un jour je ferai
partie des couleurs de l'arc-en-ciel
mois le fruit d'une relation sans
lendemain mais un mercredi matin dans le
nord à lille parce que disons le
originaire des senneurs là où le soleil
ne brille pas trop mais où le coeur des
gens véritablement est ouvert et ça du
coeur est bien la mère elle en a je
m'entende
concrètement je suis l'aîné d'une
famille composée de quatre garçons j'ai
bien dit quatre garçons maman dévouée à
ses enfants et pour autant quatre
garçons chacun d'eux père est d'origine
différente eh oui à chacun sa manière de
faire le tour du monde
je m'entends maman elle a pas eu de
chance en amour mais ce qui est certain
c'est qu'elle n'y a vu aucune fatalité
pour elle un principe tout bête la
fierté d'être maman maman de quatre
enfants quatre garçons dont elle est
certain que eux demain seront là pour
elle petit petit passage important maman
oui je t'aime et on sera là pour toi
toujours c'est certain alors pour
revenir au texte est la raison qui me
fait être aujourd'hui avec vous c'est
que maman un jour ma tin phrase qui
véritablement est resté ancré dans mon
esprit elle m'a regardé et m'a dit tu
sais mon fils ce sont les rencontres qui
participe à construire le chemin qui
dessinent nos vies est vrai philosophe
maman on dirait avec le parcours qui est
le sien il le faut je m'entends enfants
du moins adolescente elle croise le
chemin de kacem a cassé m
accessoirement il avait dit à mon père
il s'avère qu'elle tombe amoureuse
fatalement de cassel elles voient en lui
l'homme de sa vie elle dit ce certains
on va se marier avoir des enfants fonder
une famille
compliqué il faut convaincre ma grand
mère qui elle accessoirement voyez pas
kacem du bon oeil
cependant ma mère tombe enceinte mon
père lui décide de tourner le dos à ses
responsabilités voilà que des sous x
difficile pour une maman qui est né dans
les années 60 de devoir expliquer non
simplement à ses parents à ses amis
qu'elle a 18 ans et qu'elle accouche
d'un enfant seule alors à partir de là
s'en suit un chemin plus ou moins
sinueux vous le comprendrez nous sommes
quatre quatre frères de pères différents
ça a été compliqué mais elle n'a jamais
jamais baissé les bras et toujours nous
a donné l'envié d'apprendre à comprendre
ce qui se passe autour de nous
maintenant imaginons une chose imaginons
qu'on se rencontre 20 ans auparavant
on est en 2016 aujourd'hui on plonge en
j'ai 17 ans en 96 déjà j'ai pas de
lunettes
et puis je vais vous plonger dans un
contexte qui était le mien à l'époque où
bien tranquille ou quoi ce comme un bon
à mon frère tu écrases est là puisque
les buy aux au toit la hausse cuse moi
toi t'es bizarre comme mec jaloux
cherche quelque chose
non parce que si tu veux on peut
s'entendre je peux la descendre venir te
voir et expliquer qu'en vérité je
capable bardot attendez je m'emballe
scrutin mais lui est alors je suis pas
là pour vous effrayer qu'on s'entende
je reprends le principe en fait j'ai 16
ans je suis en conflit identitaire et je
suis nourrie par un seul mode de
dialogue
la violence effectivement à ce moment-là
je me dis mais attendez j'ai 16 ans j'ai
trois faire deux pères différents
on n'a de cesse de nous appelle la
famille benetton mais moi dans ma tête
ça raisonne pas comme une blague
l'une a été de color non c'est pas si
simple
et du coup je suis en colère contre
moment je lui en veux et puis les frères
j'ai pas envie de leur parler on est
différent on est de quatre couleurs
différentes
imaginez dans mon esprit déjà comme il
est compliqué pour moi avec le teint qui
aime bien entendu je suis métisse déjà
de me positionner alors quand avec mes
frères je me retrouve à l'école primaire
où on s'inscrit qui s'appelle sacré
coeur oui j'ai connu l'école des bonnes
soeurs forcément c'est compliqué ton
frère lui non il est noir a été blanc et
oh bah oui mais c'est mon frère il
s'appelle samuel durteste je m'appelle
eddy durteste quoi l'autre aussi lol
café au lait tout comme ben oui c'est
romuald urt est le dernier arrivé plus
tard si williams c'était un peu plus
facile pour lui cependant et en finalité
de tout ça il s'avère que quatre mois
après ma sortie du lycée je me retrouve
en garde à vue c'est la première fois de
ma vie je me fais arrêter 96 heures de
garde à vue
je me retrouve déféré au parquet il
retient une chose de ce moment article
125 du code pénal capable de nuire à
l'ordre public je comprends pas ce qui
se passe 4 heures du matin dans un
fourgon cellulaire et je me retrouve
dans la maison d'arrêt de loos une des
plus vétustes de france moi jeune mineur
je suis incarcéré avec les majeures
concrètement deux mois plus tard je vais
avoir 18 ans je suis au mois de janvier
je me fais arrêter le 26 novembre
j'ai pas de chance au fond mais en même
temps il se passe que je rencontre un
grand de mon quartier et qui me protège
et qui veut dire est à côté de moi
t'inquiète pas concrètement avec lui je
me retrouve dans une pièce on dit mais
toi tout nu baisse doit tous où ça me
choque le grand me dit inquiète
c'est ça la logique des choses je me
retrouve en cellule d'arrivants je
m'endors dans le lit et lendemain matin
le réveil mais je suis persuadé que j'ai
fait un cauchemar
donc du coup je cherche pas à comprendre
je sors de mon lit je suis au 3e 3e
étage vous imaginez la chute et
l'atterrissage à l'atterrissage pour moi
ça a été de me rends compte qu
effectivement j'étais bien incarcéré
problème étant c'est que je suis pas
condamné je suis en mandat de dépôt
finalité je mets deux semaines pour
sortir ne serait-ce qu'en promenade j'ai
peur j'ai peur de me faire attaquer j'ai
peur de faire égorger j'ai peur de me
faire violer voyez l'image qu'on donne
des prisons à l'extérieur on demande pas
véritablement simplement le principe
c'est que dans ma cellule ya mehdi et
betty in situ c'est eddy médy eddy médy
moi donc
elle était facile celle là c'est dit il
faut que tu sortes
il faut que tu ailles en promenade parce
que si tu sors pas tu vas t'on fermés
jeudi mais attends mais dit tu es un fou
aux frères je suis enfermé déjà dit non
à médor et à l'extérieur mais
l'extérieur de quoi va en promenade
je me dis ok je vais aller en promenade
j'arrive en promenade
la première fois médime équipe et me dit
prends une brosse à dents ramon l'a bien
protège toi et sort avec et oui
effectivement la violence existe en
prison
du coup je m'avance dans la cour de
promenade et pour principe ce qui se
passe dans une promenade c'est simple on
tourne et où si l'on se cache dans les
toilettes pour faire des trafics et
sinon quand on a je dirais position à
l'aise on s'installe au milieu de la
cour de promenade et on vaque à ses
occupations
alors moi je vous dirais que jean menait
pas large
je marche tranquillement je fais le tour
de la promenade et là tout d'un coup
j'entends par l'os ses démons sur nos
petites anecdotes on m'appelait marc
dosch pour mardi car mercredi
robinson crusoé qui parlait beaucoup mon
pote qui comprend pas que mercredi mardi
c'est pas le même parce que je parle
beaucoup fini par m'appeler mardi
ouais je viens du nord encore une fois
non plus sérieusement donc j'entends
marc dosch une fois deux fois je réponds
pas j'ai peur je me dis pourquoi pas
mais non c'est un règlement de compte
c'est sur quelqu'un qui m'ont veux
qu'ils me retrouve là et puis tout d'un
coup j'entends aux édifices à pierrette
je vous explique pour une maman seule
avec ses enfants vous avez c'est pas
facile hein oui j'ai connu une époque
assis sur un caddie ma mère qui courait
m'attendre derrière qui empêche le
vigile de nous rattraper
non pas pour voler autre chose qu'à
manger finalité en fait il s'avère que
celui qui m'appelle c'est quelqu'un qui
a connu ma mère est quelqu'un que ma
mère a aidé à une époque qui se
demandent pourquoi je suis là parce que
j'étais véritablement celui qu'on
n'attendait pas à cet endroit des
lunettes tête reposée j'arrivais
toujours à me débrouiller
ma mère elle même jamais n'aurait
imaginé me retrouver un tel endroit
finalité je m'avance et la haye me
regarde et me dit alors que tu fais un
je me saisis du pourquoi du comment
je me dis que je vais lui dire je suis
là pour violences ça va faire bien je me
suis pris une sacrée tarte
bah oui il me regarde et me dit ma tante
est un imbécile pourquoi t'es pas plus
nous voir on pourrait donner des
stupéfiantes aurait fait de l'argent la
violence ça sert à rien moralisateurs
qui veut finalité je prends ma raclée et
je me vois attendre une bouteille à
l'intérieur ce que je pensais tu jus
d'orange
faites bien de rigoler je me suis mais
rigolo si après quelques gorgées
la vérité c'est que dans le jus d'orange
en vérité ce qui se cache et c'était de
la levure voilà la meilleure manière en
prison de fer de l'alcool je me retrouve
à boire et donc à partir de là je me
retrouve à vivre autrement les choses et
je lui ai dit ça y est je suis chez moi
je suis tranquille tout se passe bien
vivre le quartier problème et en deux
semaines plus tard un maton vient me
voir et là il me regarde droit dans les
yeux et me dit durteste paquetage je me
dis ça et je m'en vais c'est bon tout
est gagné
je suis je les sens et là je fais la
rencontre improbable de gendarmes qui me
disent monsieur transfert vous êtes
disciplinaire suivez-nous étrange je me
suis pas battue j'ai rien fait de mal ça
fait deux semaines que je suis là le
seul vrai moment difficile que j'ai
vécue celle échange avec ma mère au
premier parloir qui tout d'un coup me
dit mon fils qui es tu
je te connais pas tu es pas mon fils
c'est pas possible je n'ai pas élevé
comme sa finalité je suis dans un
fourgon je fais 60 km je me retrouve
dans la maison d'arrêt d'arras et
j'apprends que je transpirais
disciplinaire parce que considérés
d'être capable d'inciter à l'émeute
je m'étonne de cette logique et avec le
recul je comprends c'est
qu'effectivement petit étant mineur dans
une cour de grands on m'accueille on met
au milieu nécessairement je deviens une
mascotte et on sait ce qui peut arriver
quand on s'en prend à une mascotte
donc on met dans une maison d'arrêt où
là je me retrouve avec une population
qui m'échappe puisque nécessairement la
maison d'arrêt où j'étais était plutôt
je dirais globaliste on retrouve de tous
les grands criminels des violeurs les
vendeurs de drogue
les braqueurs là je me retrouve dans une
maison d'arrêt entouré de gens qui sont
toxicomanes pour la plupart incarcérées
pour des faits de stupéfiants
et tout d'un coup on en fait un pendant
un mois un mois je me retrouve en
isolement dans ce qu'on appelle une
promenade camembert alors on va ensemble
faire un petit truc sympa je vais vous
apprendre comment on peut tout d'un coup
prendre considération de ce qu'est le
mot liberté et je vais rejoindre
l'intervention d'un des protagonistes
tout à l'heure et on se retrouve lui et
moi je vous invite à fermer les yeux
l'espace d'un instant tous fermé les
yeux véritablement joué je joue le jeu
avec vous je continue à parler les yeux
fermés et imaginez-vous là maintenant là
où vous souhaiteriez être depuis si
longtemps et où malheureusement il ne
vous ai pas donné possible d'aller pour
toutes les raisons qui vous concerne
imaginez juste
ouvrez les yeux vous venez de comprendre
ce qu'est la liberté quand j'ai pris
conscience de ça au bout d'un mois
j'ai demandé à voir le responsable
pénitentiaire et je lui ai dit écoutez
je suis prêt intrigué mois mettez-moi en
cellule avec quelqu'un j'ai besoin de
discuter besoin d'échanger j'ai plus
envie d'être enfermé on m'a proposé
d'intégrer une cellule et là je
rencontre christophe christophe est un
ancien toxicomane arrêté dans une
affaire de stupéfiants et qui a
raccroché
moi je viens un quartier où la drogue
est arrivé en 78 et où la plupart des
aînés sont son ont sombré véritablement
dedans pour certains mort d'overdose
pour d'autres sont tombés dans le deal
et c est moi j'avais une véritable mais
perry table haine envers le toxicomane
pour moi le toxicomane c'est quelqu'un
qui ne mérite en aucun cas qu'on
s'apitoie sur son sort ont tous les cas
qu'on s'inquiète pour lui mais finalité
avec lui j'ai appris tout autrement les
choses et j'ai une première fois pu
comprendre qu'il était important
d'apprendre à connaître les autres
ce qui est étrange puisqu'au fond ma
mère m'avait inculqué cette valeur
maintenant ce qui se passe et
effectivement ce passage étant un an
plus tard je recroise le bris car ce
responsable pénitentiaire et du fait de
mon parcours puisqu'il faut le savoir
j'ai passé un cap2 tourneur fraiseur
j'ai passé un diplôme de secourisme et
j'ai organisé des ateliers d'écriture
etc
j'anime et la cour de promenade à partir
de là il me dit écoute un jeune comme
toi ça a pas sa place en prison
moi je pense que tu es fait pour
l'extérieur pose une conditionnelle un
mot qui m'échappe
las condiciones et la possibilité donnée
un détenu qui montre un comportement
sain s'est engagé de sortir plutôt très
bien je sors plutôt à partir de là pour
moi la possibilité m'est donnée de le
saisir d'une liberté nouvelle
écrire à nouveau une vie difficile on
est jugé très vite donc je décide de
m'échapper je dis à ma mère écoute
moment d'au moins 400 france disparaît
et je suis parti pendant un an
pendant un an j'ai vague et était payant
pays en europe jusqu'à revenir chez moi
et comprendre une chose c'est que ceux
avec qui j'avais grandi n'était plus
capable de me comprendre et moi je
n'avais plus rien à partager avec eux
du coup je décide d'accepter au fond
d'aller au devant de ce qui me faisait
le plus peur
l'inconnu je décide à partir de là de
suivre le cheminement de ma vie au
travers des rencontres
j'accepte ce que ma mère m'avait
présenté comme étant une vérité et je me
retrouve à bordeaux aux aubiers finalité
installé aux aubiers je rencontre alpha
alpha jeunes sénégalais guinéens et on a
pour dénominateur commun la musique
ensemble on a une envie c'est d'animer
notre quartier les ouviers certains
peut-être levé la main connaissent les
aubiers qui a une bonne image des
aubiers soyez sincère lever la main
merci je suis là aussi pour vous
permettre de changer d'idée non
sincèrement donc alpha et moi on décide
de s'engager sur ce processus
d'animation est ensemble on monte un
collectif qui s'appelle urban vibrations
crew or souvent il en tira concis facile
urbain qu'on s'entende c'est pas pour
faire du break de la stricte du rap
c'est d'urbain au sens géographique du
terme parce qu'effectivement il émane du
contexte urbain ce que j'appelle moi des
vibrations et qu'à partir du moment où
on s'est sentis ressentir ces vibrations
on se sent tout d'un coup exister les
oublier ses 54 nationalité 4000
habitants et on vit ensemble avec alpha
du coup on est à barbe et on organise
des concerts ont fait des soirs on amène
les quartiers tout le monde et puis un
jour et les crew et chaabi décide de
nous dire les gars c'est quoi si vous
voulez aller plus loin de ma créer une
association
pourquoi pas au fond on décide de la
créé cette association en 2007 ont
déclenché les choses on monte les
statuts et pendant deux ans je
m'investis à plein pot à tel point que
je quitte mon boulot à l'époque je suis
responsable technique dans un centre
d'appels m'aura fallu deux ans j'ai
commencé conseillers clients et
j'atteins le poste que je souhaitais
obtenir mais ça ne convient plus part au
maroc je fais un voyage professionnel je
découvre la vérité des centres d'appels
là bas je vois les écarts qui existent
ça me plaît pas je suis pas d'accord
j'abandonne pas à mon poste mais je pars
pour moi la tête haute et je décide de
m'investir dans l'association
us à tel point que en 2009 je croise le
chemin de ce qui allait devenir ma
seconde maman catherine quelqu'un
d'exceptionnel ni plus ni moins que la
déléguée au préfet elle a tout d'un coup
je me dis mais tu en train d'ouvrir une
boucle bah oui la dernière fois que
j'avais une relation avec la préfecture
de police et où la préfecture en général
elles étaient pas bonnes mais là je
découvre quelqu'un d'incroyable
quelqu'un d'ouvert sincère de
volontaires de dévoués soucieuse du
devenir d'un quartier les ouviers je me
dis mais en fait je m'étais trompé donc
avec elle je décide de m'engager
puisqu'elle me propose de créer mon
poste au sein de cette association que
j'ai créé et ironie étant le poste
qu'elle me propose de créer un poste de
médiateur
moi ce gel qui au préalable m'amuser à
emmener les gens dans le pire du pire je
deviens celui qui nécessairement capable
de fonder un empire en temps leur
transmettre des valeurs très bien je
joue je avec alpha on s'engage et au
bout d'un temps il s'avère
qu'effectivement au sein des obus on
parvient à exister lyon l'association
pardon urba libération de ce couple
parvient à rayonner ce qui est tout
autant étrange c'est qu'il est difficile
pour beaucoup d' accepter qu'au fond des
jeunes puissent réussir
indépendamment d'études ou de cursus
habituel
du coup le défi pour moi était de
convaincre convaincre et à partir de là
de reprendre les racines qui était celle
que ma mère m'avait laissé aller vers
l'autre et non plus aller vers l'autre
comme tout à l'heure pour lui paraître
méchant vindicative dangereux mais pour
lui expliquer qu'il est bondé mais qu'il
est bon de donner que les rencontres
sont essentielles que nécessairement ce
qui nous constitue ce sont les
rencontres effectivement avec la
première des rencontres c'est celle avec
soi même
s'en est suivi des rencontres et des
rencontres qui m'ont amené aujourd'hui à
être là avec vous ôtez d'aix je suis dit
durteste directeur et fondateur de
l'association évaluation de school et
vous êtes ma rencontre du jour et on se
rencontrera aux oreilles et aux aubiers
pardon j'en suis sûr merci